i want to i absolutely want to talk
about labor and everything i want to
talk about this story real quick because
it segues into a discussion about jobs
and labor we have this from the
post-millennial nearly 80 percent of
americans believe u.s is in a state of
decay the poll found that 76.8 of
respondents believe american society and
culture is in a state of decay a poll
from the trafalgar group and convention
of states action published on thursday
revealed basically what i just said just
9.8 of respondents in the country is in
a state of progress so i bring this up
in in relation to what we're talking
about just because i wonder if
if our journalists can't do the job of
criticizing the establishment the
government the narratives being
objective or just countering the
authority then it seems to me like what
we're actually seeing is is tribalism
joe rogan is smeared and slammed as far
right by many of these outlets when he
challenges the establishment in this way
and these quote unquote news
organizations just shill whatever the
government or establishment line is
that says to me it's not necessarily a
representative of decay in this country
although it seems like a lot of people
seem to believe this country isn't decay
but that we've we've fractured to a
point where both sides are probably
looking at each other as the problem as
the decay in this country you know what
i mean but it's not just it's not both
sides look how many sides are really
involved in the rot
our journalists let us down in ways that
we can't even imagine
our politicians of course are in it for
the next election and they've let us
down in
i think a pretty equal way
our scientists have let us down not
because they're scientists but because
there's no consensus and they all sound
so damn certain i don't mind you again i
don't mind you being wrong
but where's the humility where did the
humility go those are three big pillars
right there that i think disappointed a
lot of people but here's a fourth and
another reason why rogan matters
comedians
our comedians have let us down the court
jester that you referenced in anderson's
tale where is he right now chappelle's
doing yeoman's work in my view but i
look around i see a lot of comedians who
well to be fair there wasn't much they
could do for a year virtually it's a
different world you know they they were
hunkered down too but the carefulness
the carefulness with which comedy has
unfolded or failed to unfold and we can
blame cancel culture we can blame speech
you know that's there's plenty to talk
about why
but they let us down too nobody was
holding anybody's feet to the fire in a
really meaningful way
some people
and that's why i you know i like the
story of the the emperor's clothes right
and and it does feel to me like it
represents a decay
it was scientists and establishment
institutions it was journalists for the
corporate press it was mainstream
politicians who are worried about their
donors they're all the ones who let us
down don't forget social media oligarchs
this was their time to shine shout out
to spotify for keeping this knowledge on
the radio yeah absolutely i mean which
robert malone the censorship that we
deal with on on youtube the censorship
on twitter the suppressing of of big
political stories it is all of these
people standing there
watching the emperor which i guess just
is the narrative nobody wanted to be the
person who would call out and say hey
guys this doesn't make sense does it as
soon as anybody did the entire crowd
turned and yelled your right wing
evil evil
and so now
over the past couple of years
we not only had joe rogan we had ricky
gervais say was it that was the oscars
or whatever when he just roasted all of
them we've had globes golden globes
that's what it was we had right we've
had ryan long i mean ryan long has been
putting out videos that have been
gaining in popularity because he's not a
right-wing guy he's just a comedian
who's poking fun
but you look we've got dr robert malone
we've got uh brett weinstein you you you
do have
scientists researchers and academics who
have been speaking up but when we look
to our institutions
that's what's failed us now joe rogan is
interesting because he kind of occupies
both spaces he's got netflix specials
he's got his mainstream arena tour arena
tours he's on spotify he's on itunes but
he's always been an independent voice
standing up for himself and what he
believes in
and that's kind of a bridge in my
opinion why he's been so important
is that regular people who don't care
for politics don't care for a narrative
listen they listen to his show and then
when he speaks out and does challenge
the system and does say fu to to all the
lies he does point at the emperor and
say you're not wearing any clothes and i
don't care
i can make a long list of things that
joe rogan said that i don't agree with
but i but i have a really hard time
finding an opinion that strikes me as
hypocritical
he's back to what we said very very
early on when when
when you get starved for authenticity
the first thing i start to look for
is
anybody
anybody whose words match up with what
they say and who if they if they
do overreach if they do get in their own
way they'll be the first to admit it so
he has
a measure of the humility that's lacking
in science in my view he certainly has a
comedian's sense of the absurd which he
uses but most importantly at least from
what i've heard
he doesn't lie
well he's willing to be wrong and he
admits when he's wrong and he's able to
look at an issue without emotionally
jumping on it and and deciding what it
is immediately and the way he he
articulates the way he kind of
fact-finds this larger question that
whatever it's asked to him he goes
through these motions the way he
describes it is is a way that's
completely totally different than the
corporate media that has pr corporate
talking points that they literally
regurgitate and speak in unison as if
they were in a religion which they are
so i want to ask you know looking back
at this poll i'm i'm wondering why
i'm wondering why people feel that the
the country is in a state of decay well
it's it's a materials issue as well
we're on 150 year old materials when
we're working with steel it's super
heavy uh it's decaying things are
rusting um and of course
here we go mike i want to ask you about
graphics
i think that we're literally
materials
i don't understand uh they don't
understand that there could be we're
going to talk about drafting in a little
bit that's that's a ridiculous segue in
no i think it's part of the decay that
people i feel like i do as well not what
people are talking about talking about
culture it's kind of society
i can help i can help with this i see
what he's trying to do and i see what
you're trying to do and what i might
suggest is at the root of this is what
um i think they call the second law of
thermodynamics right we're living in a
state of entropy we're in a
disintegrating universe to your point
russ never sleeps sooner or later it's
coming for all the steel in the world
but it's also coming for our best
thoughts and our best ideas and the
things that we hold most deer that stuff
also has a shelf life and it has to be
nurtured it has to be watered it has to
be challenged
um and and when we stop doing that and
accept being having our belly scratched
or having getting letting ourselves be
patted on the head right that's a bad
substitute for that and that's not how
you fight newton's second law
well i i agree with you um but i wanted
to
i think we have to have a more direct
segue into this idea yeah there is there
is infrastructure decay in this country
we're not our roads are falling apart
our bridges are falling apart we're not
interested in these big projects i often
talk about how uh you know i'm in new
york and i'm crossing the williamsburg
bridge just looking at this monolith of
a structure that's existed since before
i was born as far as i know it's just
there and i get to use it nobody charges
me any money for it i can walk right
across it and those are those big
projects where effectively our society
said we're going to plant a tree whose
shade we know we will never sit beneath
and that means the next generations will
benefit from it i when i when i look at
this country as an estate of decay it's
because
it's it's for that it's for this reason
i see people self-interested trying to
extract as much as they can they feel
like the titanic is sinking and they're
trying to grab as much fine china and
silver where they can before they get on
that boat and get out of here leave us
all left you know drowning there's no
community anymore but but what i wanted
to say was i don't want to get too
negative with it because i'm wondering
if you know seeing joe rogan speak up
seeing his massive success is actually
an optimistic point
that we actually are seeing people
come together around certain ideas and
that decay is actually being reversed
yeah the people stealing the china don't
want a community and that's why i think
there's been such a concerted effort to
push a divide and conquer agenda that of
course puts people in different
political
you know associations and gangs and
affiliations but
we have to also recognize if someone is
watching the corporate media non-stop
they are living in a totally different
world than someone who doesn't watch the
corporate media who does their own
homework who does does their own
research and actually gets their
information from different sources and
is able to actually discern information
for themselves rather than just hear
you know opinions and talking points
that is the establishment narrative so
these two different worlds are of course
going to be clashing with each other
because these are different realities
that people are living under that are
completely playing by different set of
rules that the other other one is not
playing by i think you're i think your
metaphor is pretty great i mean if if
the economy that we're talking about
here or
our country is the titanic
right and if we're talking a post
iceberg titanic right the damage has
been rendered
right we're on the clock and things are
slowly devolving if that's if that's
where we are right now what's going on
on the deck right some people are taking
to china some people are angling for
lifeboats some men are doing about the
most incredibly selfless thing there is
and stepping aside others aren't others
are putting on wigs and dressing like
women to get on the boats meanwhile you
got a captain who's got so much nobility
baked into him that he's absolutely 100
going down with the ship and then you
have four dudes who fascinate me more
than anybody else the guys in the string
quartet who are playing near my god to
thee providing a soundtrack unlike any
other for one of the greatest weirdest
disasters of all time and then you have
the cook
you know true story the last guy in the
water was the cook
and he was blind drunk and he helped a
lot of people into the uh the lat
into the lifeboats his name was joffin
charles joffin was the last guy in the
water and the only one to go into the
water who lived
and you can look him up and you'll love
his story point being there was a lot
going on on the deck of the titanic post
collision and there's a lot going on in
our country right now that belies that
percentage i'm getting the feeling that
some people are stealing the fuel out of
the boats and taking 20-person lifeboats
and getting on them by themself and
trying to have like these rich
and it's
not only are they taking the the little
trinkets they're taking our fuel they're
just by printing money they're ruining
our economy they're destroying any hope
we have of getting out of here my single
biggest regret in this whole thing in
terms of stuff i've said on the public
record
late in march i did one of the first
zoom shows right
after the lockdowns it was with the
captains of the deadliest catch and i
said to sink hanson in the middle of the
show you know for the first time and
these are crab fishermen by the way just
to stick with the nautical metaphor i
said for the first time in my life it
really truly seems like we're all in the
same boat right 15 days to flatten the
curve we're coming together we're going
to do it we're on the same boat oh
bullcrap you know what we're all in the
same storm but to your point
our boats are very different that guy's
in a dinghy that guy's in a yacht right
that guy's in a freighter that guy's
hanging onto a piece of driftwood
wondering if anybody's gonna pick him up
right so we have never been in the same
boat
ever once but
for the first time in my life we really
truly were in the same storm
and dude that's amazing because
if you think of every other disaster
that you've lived through right i can
think of hurricanes up the gulf i can
think of the wildfires in in northern
california the dereko that just knocked
cedar rapids the inland hurricane right
we've got plagues of ants we got all
this other stuff but they all affect
very very specific parts of our country
this was different this turned our whole
country into the titanic and whether
you're rearranging the life
the the deck chairs or playing near my
god to thee you know everybody's got
that the world too like 911 brought the
us together kind of for a few weeks but
this is the whole world thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm now
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you